Sammeln und deutlich buchstabieren.
Ja, der Vorname ist P-A-U-L Paul.
Und der Familienname ist M-Y-N-D-E-R.
Wie alt sind Sie und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin 69 und werde dieses Jahr 70. geboren am 18.09.56.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Münder?
Ich bin 1,74.
Wissen Sie, wie viel Sie wiegen?
Wie bitte?
Ja, also immer so um die 83, 84 Kilo.
83? Okay.
Was willst du denn heute zu uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe eine komische Stelle am Bein.
Die ist schon, ja, ich habe da schon lange.
Aber jetzt ist das mit einem mal so schlecht geworden.
Und zwar, da habe ich mich mal verletzt.
Beim Fahrradfahren bin ich so abgerutscht.
Und da habe ich jetzt immer so eine kleine Stelle.
Eine kleine, offene Stelle.
Und jetzt wird die aber immer größer.
Und jetzt tut sie auch richtig weh.
Und was mich wirklich so ein bisschen erschreckt hat,
da läuft jetzt mit einem mal so komische Flüssigkeit raus.
Und ich wollte eigentlich zu meinem Hausarzt gehen,
aber der hat jetzt Urlaub während der Feiertage.
Und deswegen habe ich da keinen erreicht.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, Mensch, dann komme ich doch lieber zu Ihnen,
bevor das jetzt mit den Feiertagen losgeht.
Denn das sieht gar nicht schön aus.
Und das ist auch ganz dick und spannend, das Bein.
Ja, es tut mir leid, dass Sie solche Beschwerden haben, Herr Wiminda.
Und Sie haben die richtige Entscheidung getroffen, hierher zu kommen.
Aber ich möchte Ihre Beschwerden zusammenfassen.
Sie haben einen Fahrradunfall erlebt.
Nein, das ist schon ganz lange her.
Da bin ich nur mal so ein bisschen dagegen gestoßen gegen die Pedale.
Und dann gab es halt so eine kleine offene Stelle.
Das ist schon lange her.
Das ist im letzten Herbst gewesen.
Das ist schon Monate her.
Und seither ist es nie richtig zugeheilt.
Und jetzt wird es mit einem mal so viel größer.
Und das Bein schült an.
Und jetzt nässt es eben so.
Und da läuft so richtig die Soße runter.
Das ist ganz furchtbar.
Verstanden.
Und wo genau diese Verletzung?
Ja, das ist am rechten Bein unten.
So am Knöchel, innen.
Beim Knöchel.
Okay, das habe ich gut verstanden.
Und danach leiden Sie diese ungeheilten Wunden.
Und deswegen sind Sie hier.
Hab ich richtig verstanden?
Ja, klar.
Und weil das so dick und blau ist, das Bein, das sieht auch schrecklich aus.
Dick und blau.
Okay.
Ja, Herr Minder, seit wann leiden Sie darunter?
Ich meine die Wunde.
Seit Herbstferien oder seit Kürzen?
Nein, seit letztem Herbst.
Das ist bestimmt mehr als ein halbes Jahr.
Okay, das habe ich verstanden.
Und leiden Sie auch Schmerzen in diesem Stelle?
Ja, das war bisher nicht so schlimm.
Aber jetzt wird es eben so unangenehm.
Und es tut richtig weh.
Und das Bein spannt eben auch so.
Okay.
Und die andere Teil Ihres Beins, sind Sie gerötet, gewärmt?
Ja, es ist ganz prall und blau.
Prall und blau.
Okay.
Und haben Sie keine Schmerzen in dieser Stelle?
Haben Sie Fieberstörungen?
Nein, jetzt habe ich Schmerzen. Natürlich habe ich Schmerzen.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Skala?
Wobei 0 keine Schmerzen und 10 die stärksten Schmerzen bedeutet.
Aber man kann das ja aushalten.
Also würde man in der Mitte sagen, so bei 5.
Könnten Sie das aushalten bis zum Ende des Gesprächs?
Ja, aber ich habe das jetzt schon lange.
Okay, das habe ich verstanden.
Könnten Sie mir diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Stichend, brennend oder?
Das konnte ich nicht gut verstehen.
Ich habe das auch noch nicht. Schmerzen beschreiben ist so schwierig.
Ja, also jetzt sticht es schon und diese Spannung, das ist so ein Druckgefühl.
Druckgefühl?
Ja, vielleicht stechend.
Stechend beschreibt es ganz gut.
Und je nachdem, wenn man da irgendwo gegen kommt, dann brennt das natürlich auch diese offene Stelle.
Offene Stelle. Und es gibt...
Es gibt eine Flüssigkeit und die Wunde ist ein Nest.
Und gibt es eine gestörte Gerüche mit dieser Wunde?
Was gibt es?
Gerüche, ich meine, stinkt das?
Stinkt die Wunde?
Ja, stinkt das.
Also ich habe das jetzt nicht bemerkt. Meine Frau hat sich auch nicht beschwert.
Also ich denke mal, das riecht nicht, würde ich sagen.
Okay, die Farbe. Und ich würde gerne wissen, die Farbe dieser Sekret.
Ja, das ist freundlich.
Braunlich?
Ja.
Okay, das habe ich notiert. Danke für alle diese Informationen.
Sie sind sehr wichtig für uns, eine richtige oder genaue Diagnose zu stellen.
Und waren Sie deswegen beim Arzt? Oder ist das zum ersten Mal?
Ja, das ist jetzt zum ersten Mal.
Okay, nehmen Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente ein? Eingenommen? Haben Sie eingenommen?
Nein, am Anfang habe ich da mal Pflaster drauf gemacht und dann habe ich mal ein bisschen Salbe drauf geschmiert.
So ein bisschen Fettcreme. Aber das hat ja alles nicht geholfen.
Okay, was für eine Salbe haben Sie darauf aufgetreten?
Ja, so eine Fettsalbe, damit es irgendwie besser wird. Aber das hat nicht geholfen.
Okay, das habe ich verstanden. Haben Sie Fieber, Stellfrost, Nachtschweiß oder kalter Schweiß?
Nee, zum Glück nicht. Ich fühle mich eigentlich nicht krank.
Okay. Haben Sie Brustschmerzen, Atemnot oder Herzrasen?
Nein, ich komme wegen meines Beines.
Ja, das kann ich gut verstehen. Aber manchmal gibt es zusammenhänge. Es können zusammenhangen in dem ganzen Körper.
Zusammenhänge geben.
Ja, geben. Deswegen habe ich danach gefragt. Oder muss ich danach fragen.
Okay, ist Ihnen übel oder müssten Sie sich übergeben?
Nein, nein. Mein Magen ist ganz in Ordnung.
Okay. Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nee, zum Glück noch nicht.
Wie sieht es mit dem Stuhlgang aus?
Also, manchmal bin ich ein bisschen verstopft.
Verstopft. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Der ist eigentlich gut.
Seit wann leiden Sie darunter, Herr Münder?
Wohl leide ich darunter?
Ja, ich meine Appetitlosigkeit. Sie haben das erwähnt.
Ich habe guten Appetit.
Guten Appetit. Okay, das habe ich falsch verstanden. Entschuldigen Sie.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewollt ab oder zu genommen?
Also, so viel ich weiß. Eigentlich passen alle Hosen. Ich wiege mich auch nicht so wie jeden Tag. Aber hin und wieder mal. Das ist eigentlich stabil. Immer frei.
Und schlafen Sie gut? Oder haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Ja, ganz gut schlafe ich eigentlich nicht.
Okay, das habe ich notiert. Gibt es etwas, das Ihre Beschwerden, ich meine diese Schmerzen und diese Druckgefühle verstärkt oder lindert?
Zum Beispiel Körperverlegerung oder Hochlage.
Wenn ich morgens aufstehe, ist das Bein nicht ganz so prall und dick. Und wenn ich dann aber aus dem Bett aufstehe und ins Badezimmer gehe, dann schießen die Schmerzen natürlich so richtig rein.
Sie haben kein Fieber, das ist auch wichtig. Und Sie haben keine Brustschmerzen, Atemnot oder ähnliches.
Gibt es in Ihrer Vorgeschichte Krankheiten, von denen ich wissen sollte, zum Beispiel chronische Erkrankungen wie Brutzuckerkrankheit oder erhöhte Blutwertwerte?
Also bisher war das einzige, was ich weiß, dass ich ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck habe. Und ich trage halt ein Hörgerät und deswegen habe ich immer wieder Mittelohrentzündungen.
Mittelohrentzündungen leiden Sie da, oder? Okay. Wie oft leiden Sie daran? Ich meine die Mittelohrentzündung.
Ja, also zuletzt war das vor drei Wochen. Das kommt eigentlich immer wieder, also vielleicht alle zwei Monate oder so.
Alle zwei Monate leiden Sie daran. Okay, das ist auch wichtig für uns. Und Sie leiden an arterieller Bluthochdruck. Seit wann leiden Sie daran?
Oh, das hat man so vor 10, 12 Jahren festgestellt. Okay, und ich denke die Blutdruckmessungen sind normal.
Oh, habe ich richtig verstanden. Sie haben es gerade erwähnt? Nein, das habe ich nicht gesagt. Ich habe nur gesagt, ich habe einen Blutdruck und deswegen muss ich halt Medikamente nehmen.
Oh, okay. Das habe ich. Entschuldigen Sie. Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie dagegen ein? Also ich nehme HCT. Ich weiß gar nicht wofür das ist. Und Zufenopril.
Könnten Sie das wiederholen? HCT und Zufenopril. Zufenopril, Zufenopril, okay. Das habe ich notiert. Wie war die Dosierung? Könnten Sie sich daran erinnern?
Bei Zufenopril, das ist fünf. Ich weiß nicht was. Und dann muss ich morgens und abends eine nehmen. Zwei Mal. Und das HCT 25 nehme ich morgens eine.
Und dann nehme ich noch Aspirin eine am Mittag. So eine Aspirin 100. Aus welchem Grund nehmen Sie Aspirin?
Ja, das ist schon ewig lange. Hat mein Hausarzt mir irgendwann mal empfohlen, dass das gut wäre, damit man die Blutgerinnung verbessert. Ja genau.
Seit ich eine Thrombose hatte. Ich hatte in dem rechten Bein vor fünf Jahren eine Thrombose.
Das ist sehr wichtig für mich diese Information. Danke für die Informationen.
Und dann habe ich erst natürlich so Makuma bekommen. Und dann als ich nach einem halben Jahr hatte der Hausarzt dann gesagt, ich könnte diese Aspirin eben nehmen.
Ich möchte das zusammenfassen. Vor fünf Jahren hatten Sie eine Thrombose im rechten Bein.
Ja, deswegen haben Sie damals dagegen Makuma sechs Monate lang. Danach diese Makuma wurde ausgesetzt.
Ok, das habe ich verstanden. Und ich meine danach diese Beschwerden. Hatten Sie Probleme damit?
Seit nicht mehr.
Ok, und jetzt sind Sie hier mit einem rechten Bein Problem. Ok, vielen Dank. Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Lassen Sie mich überlegen. Ich wüsste nicht.
Keine Operation?
Nein, als Kind nicht. Und jetzt, nein, die letzten Jahre zum Glück auch nicht.
Danke. Und sind Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt Herr Minder?
Ja, ich darf keine Meeresfrüchte essen. Also kein Fisch, keine Muscheln, keine Krabben und diese ganzen Geschichten da.
Da habe ich einmal eine heftige Reaktion bekommen. Und das war fast so, dass ich dann auch keine Luft mehr bekommen habe.
Und dann gab es mal eine Handkräber auf die ich reagiert habe. Die habe ich nicht vertragen. Aber ich glaube das ist nur bei einer Sorte gewesen.
Ok, Sie haben mehr Frühstück Allergie und diese Allergie äußert sich mit Handkräben und Atemnotproblemen.
Ja, genau.
Das ist auch für mich wichtig. Und haben Sie Unverträglichkeiten Herr Minder?
Meeresfrüchte vertrage ich nicht halt. Aber sonst?
Das habe ich als Allergie.
Und Herr Minder, darf ich fragen ob Sie rauchen oder ob Sie früher geraucht haben?
Früher habe ich geraucht, aber seit 18 Jahren rauche ich jetzt schon nicht mehr. Aber früher habe ich im Päckchen am Tag schon geraucht.
20 Päckchen am Tag. Und zuerst möchte ich Sie gratulieren, weil Sie damit aufgehört haben.
Aber schwer genug.
Ja, seit 18 Jahren rauchen Sie nicht. Wie lange haben Sie geraucht? 20 Zigaretten. Sie haben eben schon erweckt.
Ja, bestimmt 30 Jahre lang.
30 Jahre, ok. Und trinken Sie Alkohol Herr Minder?
Gelegentlich trinke ich mal ein Bier. Und wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt, trinkt man auch mal ein Sekt oder ein Schnäpschen.
Aber eigentlich eher selten. Also Bier schon ziemlich regelmäßig.
Was meinen Sie mit regelmäßig?
Ja, vielleicht so zweimal in der Woche oder dreimal in der Woche. Und im Sommer wenn es heiß ist auch mal eins mehr.
Und Sekt? Wie oft?
Ja, wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt. Also feiert man nicht Geburtstag oder Weihnachten oder was auch immer.
Das habe ich verstanden. Also Herr Minder, routinemäßig muss ich Sie fragen, ob Sie mit irgendwelchen Drogen Kontakt haben.
Ich mit Drogen? Nein. Also nö, wirklich nicht. Nein, Drogen habe ich noch nie probiert.
Ja, gut zu hören. Vielen Dank. Und haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit oder zu Hause?
Ja, bei der Arbeit ja Gott sei Dank nicht mehr. Ich bin der Rentner. Zu Hause ist es natürlich schon ein bisschen stressig.
Meine Frau hatte vor zwei Jahren einen Herzinfarkt.
Und sie ist also sehr kränklich und sie ist auch nicht mehr mobil.
Sie sitzt im Rollstuhl überwiegend und da muss ich natürlich viel helfen und für Sie da sein.
Das ist schön das zu hören. Danke.
Ja, Frau, Herr Minder. Herr Minder, waren Sie in letzter Zeit aus dem Land oder aus dem Ausland?
Aus dem Ausland? Nein, im Ausland waren wir nicht.
Sind Ihre Eltern gesund oder haben Sie Probleme?
Meine Eltern leben natürlich schon nicht mehr. Ich bin ja schon so alt.
Und mein Vater, ja, der hatte, was ganz komisch ist, der hatte in den Gallengängen irgendwie Tumore.
Und ja, der ist also gar nicht so alt geworden. Und meine Mutter, die hatte auch Darmprobleme.
Und hat dann noch einen künstlichen Darmausgang bekommen.
Und ja, die war aber dann auch schon 86, als sie verstorben ist.
Entschuldigung, das habe ich nicht gut verstehen.
Ihre Mutter hat dann Probleme, deswegen, oder was für ein Problem hat Ihre Mutter?
Ja, sie hatte eine schwere Darmerkrankung und brauchte einen künstlichen Darmausgang.
Oder war das Krebs oder? Das weiß ich gar nicht genau.
Oder eine chronische entzündliche Darmerkrankung und vielleicht Morgus oder Mopskran.
Ist sie daran verstorben?
Ja, letztendlich war sie alt. Dann kommt ja dann immer alles zusammen.
Ok, Sie sind Rentner, was haben Sie beruflich gemacht?
Ich war Angestellter in der Verwaltung.
Angestellter in der Verwaltung. Und Sie sind verheiratet?
Ja, aber die sind natürlich schon groß.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie und sind Sie gesund?
Zwei Kinder, die sind gesund, ja.
Herr Münder, ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Offenheit und Ihre Geduld.
Laut Ihrer Beschwerde habe ich den Verdacht auf eine Wundheilungsstörung bei Ihnen.
Höchstwahrscheinlich wegen Ihren vorherigen Gefäßproblemen am Bein, am rechten Bein.
Vielleicht gibt es eine Verengung oder Verschluss in Ihrem Bein.
Was kann man dagegen machen?
Aber das bleibt nur eine Vermutung. Deswegen muss ich weitere Untersuchungen durchführen, um das zu bestätigen.
Zunächst werde ich die körperliche Untersuchungen, etwas Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Ich werde eine EKG schreiben, um eine mögliche Herzursache auszuschließen.
Kann das was mit dem Herz tun?
Ja, als luthinemäßiges und wichtiges Erfahren sollten wir das machen.
Als wichtige Untersuchungen werde ich Ihren Bein mit Ultraschall untersuchen.
Ist das denn weh?
Nein, das ist eine schmerzfreie Methode, die etwa 10 oder 15 Minuten dauert.
Damit können wir Ihre Gefäße richtig und genau beurteilen, ob es Probleme gibt.
Praktisch und häufig verwendet. Sie brauchen keine Angst.
Sobald Ihre Befunde vorliegen, beschiebe ich alles mit meinem Oberarzt.
Dann komme ich zu Ihnen zurück und erkläre Ihnen Schritt für Schritt, wie es weitergeht.
Das klingt gut.
Bitte warten Sie hier und ich komme gleich.
Wunderbar.
Möchte jemand noch eine Frage stellen?
Er hat wirklich sehr vollständig gefragt und war sehr geduldig.
Ja, das sieht er glaube ich gar nicht, dass er hier die ganzen Applauskurven kriegt.
Darf ich fragen?
Aber natürlich.
Wie groß ist die Wunder?
Oh, weiß ich gar nicht so genau. Wie groß ist die? Ja, inzwischen ist die vielleicht so groß wie ein Euro-Stück.
Dankeschön.
Darf ich fragen?
Immer? Ja.
Können Sie das Bein normal bewegen? Oder haben Sie ein Taubheitsgefühl oder ein Krebsgefühl?
Also das habe ich verstanden, ob ich es bewegen kann. Ich kann das Bein bewegen, aber es tut mir ein bisschen weh, weil es so gespannt ist.
Und das andere war die Frage, habe ich nicht verstanden.
Haben Sie Krebsgefühl oder ein Taubheitsgefühl?
Ein Taubheitsgefühl, das habe ich nicht verstanden. Nein, ein Taubheitsgefühl habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Natürlich.
Haben Sie bemerkt eine Überwärmung im betroffenen Bereich?
Ja, ein bisschen warm fühlt sich das Bein an.
Überwärmung, ja?
Danke schön.
Darf ich fragen?
Ja, gerne.
Okay. Herr Ninder, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Oh Gott, das ist schon so lange her. Aber alles, was man als alter Mensch haben muss, diese Corona-Impfung habe ich natürlich gemacht.
Und die Grippe-Impfung habe ich auch gemacht.
Und dann diese Impfung gegen Lungenentzündung, das soll man ja auch irgendwie so eine Impfung machen.
Ach, habe ich alles und hier. Ganz scheußlich war das mit der Gürtelrose.
Ja, mein Hausarzt, der ist, was das Impfen angeht, ist der ganz fit.
Ich möchte wissen insbesondere gegen Tetanus.
Nochmal bitte?
Ich möchte wissen besonders gegen Tetanus.
Ach so, Tetanus.
Tetanus, das macht man ja nur, wenn man sich irgendwie im Garten verletzt hat oder so.
Aber das habe ich auch mal gehabt, aber das ist bestimmt schon lange her.
Okay. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ob ich Geschwister habe?
Sind Sie Geschwister? Ja.
Ja, ich habe zwei Brüder, aber ich habe da wenig Kontakt eigentlich mit denen.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ich habe noch einen Fragen.
Ja, da ist noch jemand der fragen möchte, ja?
Sie haben ja schon gesagt, dass Sie ein Hörgerät tragen.
Aus welchem Grund tragen Sie Hörgerät und auf welcher Seite haben Sie Mittelohrenentzündung?
Ja, ich habe das Hörgerät links, weil ich schlecht höre.
Ich habe da große Probleme gehabt, habe gemerkt, dass ich nicht mehr gut verfolgen kann, wenn gesprochen wird.
Und da habe ich auch diese Mittelohrenentzündung immer wieder.
Darf ich fragen?
Gerne.
Leider habe ich es nicht verstanden, wo genau diese Wunde ist.
Am linken Innenknöchel, oder am rechten Innenknöchel?
Richtigen Innenknöchel.
Okay, mal nur.
Also Fußgelenk unten.
Okay, danke.
Das waren ja heute viele Fragen.
Aber ich freue mich immer, weil ich das klasse finde, dass Sie alle richtig gut dabei sind und engagiert mitarbeiten.
Das macht richtig Spaß, mit der Gruppe hier zurzeit zu arbeiten.
Und im Augenblick ist es gerade für mich ein ganz schönes Bild, weil ich so viele bunte Klecks sehe.
Jeder hat eine andere Farbe und einige haben ja auch keine Bilder oder so etwas.
Aber es ist gerade so ein schönes, buntes Bild.
Bei Ihnen wahrscheinlich auch.
Herr Dr. Dogan, wie weit sind Sie denn?
So weit, aber ich kann versuchen.
Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob mein Verdachtdiagnose oder die Veranstaltung wichtig ist.
Ganz viel anderes kann es ja nicht sein.
Da ist eine technische Kleinigkeit.
Wenn Sie stark nach unten gucken, ist das Mikro nicht gut.
Wenn Sie nach oben gucken, kann ich Sie besser hören.
Ist das besser?
Es ist sowieso ein Lärm, wenn Sie mich angucken.
Sollen Sie auch in der Gruppe machen.
Wegen der technischen Probleme konnte ich nicht.
Aber wenigstens haben wir nicht die gleichen Probleme wie beim letzten Mal.
Das hat mir so leid getan für die Kollegin, die da betroffen war.
Weil das wirklich die ganze Anamnese total murkig gemacht hat.
Und ich bin sehr froh, dass wir diese technischen Probleme heute nicht haben.
Gut, ja, dann legen Sie los.
Ja, guten Tag, Frau Wichmann.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich möchte diese Patientin berichten.
Über diese Patientin.
Diesen Patientin?
Diesen Patientin berichten. Darf ich vorstellen?
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, es geht um Paul Münder.
Er ist 69 Jahre alt.
Geboren am 18.9.1900.
Er ist 1,74 Meter groß und wiegt 83 Kilogramm.
Er kam heute zu uns wegen seines sechs Monats.
Sechs Monate bestehende Heilungsstörungen und ungehalte Wunden und Schmerzen.
Laut Aussage des Patienten sind diese Schmerzen,
nach einer Verletzung mit dem Fahrrad aufgetreten.
Seitdem leiden sie darunter.
Und warum ist er jetzt gekommen?
Wie bitte?
Warum ist er dann ausgerechnet jetzt gekommen?
Weil die Wunde nicht rechtzeitig oder nicht geheilt ist.
Ja gut, da hätte man ja schon längst kommen können.
Aber was war denn los mit der Wunde?
Weil die Wunde sich entzündet.
Kann ich so sagen.
Okay, was hat er denn für Beschwerden?
Der Patient bemerkt, dass die Wunde eine braune Flüssigkeit hat und nicht gut riecht.
Auch ein geschwollener und geröteter Bein.
Und deswegen ist die Prälung noch so groß wie am Anfang?
Nein, das war kleiner.
Aber die Wunde ist im Laufe der Zeit größer geworden.
Das ist natürlich doof.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum die Patientin hierher gekommen ist.
Der Patient berichtet, dass diese Schmerzen in linken Knochen lokalisiert werden.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung werde ich die Größe dieser Wunde...
Sagen Sie nochmal, wo die lokalisiert ist. Wo ist die Wunde?
In den Knochen. Linken Knochen.
Knochen heißt das nicht?
Nein, nein. Linken Bein. Genau, Lokalisation meine ich.
Das habe ich vielleicht falsch verstanden. Linken Bein?
Nein, also am rechten Bein?
Rechten Bein, Trombose, aber Linken Bein.
Rechte Bein, Trombose, rechte Bein, Ulcus.
Also die Wunde ist am rechten Innenknochen.
Innenen Knochen.
Innenen Knöcheln heißt das. Und irgendjemand hat schon den Fachbegriff Maleolus.
Maleolus, ja. Ich soll es so sagen, natürlich.
In diesem Bereich.
Beim Schlaßdekan.
Ja, die Schmerzintensität liegt 5 von 10 auf der NRS.
Nach Angaben des Patienten sind die Schmerzen drückend.
Außerdem erwähnt er, dass er vor fünf Jahren eine Trombose im rechten Bein oder TVT im Recht erlitten hat.
Deswegen hat er sechs Monate lang Marcuma eingenommen.
Danach, reibungslos, ja, danach hatte er keine Probleme damit.
Und Vegetative anamnestisch ergaben sich Verstopfung und Müdigkeit.
Fachbegriff?
Obzipation natürlich.
Ich darf manchmal prüfen, möchte ich nicht. Deswegen habe ich es so gesagt.
Fertig und Obzipation.
Fertig nicht.
Oder nicht fertig.
Insomnie, ne?
Wie bitte?
Insomnie?
Nein, ja auch insomnie, Entschuldigung.
An Vorerkrankungen leidet er seit zwölf Jahren an arteriärer Hypertonie.
Keine Operation hat er berichtet.
Der Patient nimmt HCT 25 mg einmal morgens täglich und SOFIN OPRIL 5 mg morgens und abends täglich.
Und auch ASPW 100 mg einmal morgens.
Der Patient hat mehres Frühstück Allergie, die sich durch Parasite und Düstnä auslöst.
Bei der Noxon-Anamnese berichtet der Patient über einen Nikotinkonsum von 30 Pekias.
Seit 18 Jahren ist er nicht Raucher und den Konsum von zwei Gläsern Bier pro Woche und gelegentlich Sekt-Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Bei der Familienanamnese ergab er Kola-Geokarzinom beim Vater und unbekannte Darmerkrankungen bei der Mutter.
Sozialanamnistisch ist er Rentner. Früher hat er als Angestellter an der Verwaltung gearbeitet.
Er ist verheiratet und hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Nach dem anamnistischen Angaben habe ich den Verdacht auf eine Wundheilungsstörung im Rahmen TVT.
Dafür sprechen verspätete Heilungsprozesse, entzündliche Wunde und die Vorgeschichte des Patienten mit TVT.
Die Differenzialdiagnostik kommt unkontrolliert.
Diese Frage wurde nicht gestellt, deswegen kann ich nicht Differenzialdiagnostik Diabet nennen.
Vielleicht nicht erkannt, das könnte ja durchaus sein.
Ja, das kann sein.
Differenzialdiagnostik kommen Diabetes, Meditus, Zypstheiz und vielleicht Raucherbein in Betracht.
In meiner Verdachtsdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich zunächst natürlich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung besonders?
Besonders bei der Wundebereich und auch bei der Lunge.
Welche Aspekte nehmen Sie besonders warm?
An den Beinen?
Die Pulse, natürlich. Ich werde die Pulse auf Pulse achten.
Nur an diesen Beinen?
Die Malolus?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Bei beiden Beinen.
Im Vergleich.
Und was gucken Sie noch an?
Allein mit Ihren Augen?
Ich schaue, ob der Raucherbein gerötet oder geschwollen ist.
Und auch die Wundersikrate.
Und die Größe der Wunde.
Auch die Hautfarbe. Ob es blau oder dunkel ist.
Blau oder dunkel?
Und die Wunde. Worauf gucken Sie da?
Und auch die Tief.
Die Tief?
Es ist wichtig, ob es seine Osteomialitis gibt.
Also dass sie so tief geht.
Ja.
Wir haben einmal die Größe der Wunde.
Wir haben potenziell die Tiefe.
Wir haben die Farbe des Beines.
Aber ob es einen Belag gibt auf der Wunde.
Ist das beiträglich belegt? Ist das schwierig?
Das muss man auch mit angucken.
Gut. Und was machen Sie sonst diagnostisch mit dem Patienten?
Auch die Dopplex-Utrason ist sehr wichtig.
Ob es eine Verschluss oder Trombös gibt.
Das ist eine entscheidende Untersuchungsmethode für uns.
Besonders bei diesem Fall.
Und natürlich im Labor ist es auch wichtig.
Was bestimmen Sie im Labor besonders?
Ja, Labor auf jeden Fall eine Wundekultur aus Flüssigkeit.
Wundflüssigkeit oder nehme ich.
Wow, richtig. Abstrich. Sehr gut. Ja.
Aber wir waren gerade bei der Blutuntersuchung.
Natürlich.
Welche Blutparameter lassen Sie denn bestimmen?
Ich werde im Labor Blutbild und auch Entzündungsparameter.
Einschließlich Procalcitonin.
Das ist auch wichtig bei diesem Fall.
Und Leber- und Nierenwerte. Elektrolyte auch wichtig.
Und Hämoglobin A1c. Blutzucker.
Ob der Unterrichter in versteckten Diabetes hat? Ja, sehr gut.
Und auch Entzündungsparameter. Einschließlich Dedimer.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und auch L-D-H.
Weil es eine... Ja, L-D-H.
Und ich werde auch bei diesem Fall Blutgasanalyse kontrollieren lassen.
Ja, gegen Laktatspiegel vielleicht.
Okay, gut. Und... Ja.
Was würden Sie sonst diagnostisch noch weiter machen?
Sonst kann man eigentlich nicht viel machen, oder?
Ja, diese Unter... Ich denke erste Schritte können diese Untersuchungen ausreichend sein.
Und wie wäre denn die Therapie?
Ja, gegebenenfalls kann ich auch CT-Angio veranlassen.
Aber wie gesagt...
In welchem Fall machen Sie das?
Wenn ich meine Verdachtstheorose...
Oder wenn ich nicht richtig...
Bei einer starken Verdachtstheorose, aber wenn der Fall nicht nachgewiesen ist.
Ja, wenn Sie also keine Gefäßveränderung im venösen Bereich nachweisen können, sondern vermuten, dass das was Artäielles ist.
Ja, ja, natürlich. Weil eine meiner Verdachtstheorosen ist Raucherbein, wurde ich auch gegebenenfalls...
Dann macht das CT-Angio Sinn, oder?
Ja, CT-Angio veranlassen auch.
Und sollte sich die Verdachtstheorose bestätigen, würde ich diese Patientin auf jeden Fall...
Diese Patienten?
Ja, ja.
Wollen wir noch einmal?
Diesen Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Und auch... Ja.
Was machen Sie mit ihm?
Ja, ich werde...
Flüssigkeit, Zufuhr und Elektrolysis-Substitution auch symptomatisch Antianalgetikum verabreichen oder verordnen.
Und auch nach dem Kultur werde ich oder verabreiche ich Antibiotikum.
Wenn wir da einen Erreger drauf haben?
Ja, einen Erreger drauf.
Und was machen Sie mit der Wunde?
Ja, Wunderversorgung ist sehr wichtig in diesem Fall. Eine gute oder passende Versorgung führe ich durch.
Ja, was ist denn passend bei einer zentrierenden Wunde? Was brauchen Sie?
Ja, bei diesem Fall die Infekt- oder Gangrenuse oder Teile oder Flüssigkeit, Sekretien entfernen.
Entfernen? Ja, bzw. Sie brauchen eine Wundauflage.
Sie machen die Wunde sauber und danach brauchen Sie eine saugende Wundauflage, die diese Sezernierung auffängt.
Sie brauchen also einen Multiabsorber.
Und es gibt ja jede Menge Spezialverbände, Verbandmaterial, Alginatverbände oder Silberoberflächen oder so was.
Und was machen Sie noch mit dem Bein?
Der Patient nimmt schon Aspirin, 100 mg.
Das ist schon mal gut, ja.
Vielleicht, je nach einer kardio-gefäss-chirurgischen Konsultation, werde ich die Aspirin-Dosierung auf 300 mg steigern.
Und auch Herparin ist wichtig als antikoagulative Therapie.
Solange er liegt, oder wie?
Ja.
Und was machen Sie mit dem Bein noch?
Bei dem Bein noch, ja. Und Hochlagerung ist sehr wichtig.
Und was noch?
Hochlagerung und Mobilisation, äh, Kompression, Entschuldigung.
Ja, sehr gut.
Bei diesem Fall wichtig, weil eine mögliche Embollis oder wahrscheinlich Embollis zu vermeiden.
Ja, überhaupt Kompression auch für die Bundheilung, oder? Ja, sehr gut.
Ja, auch für die Bundheilung.
Und vielleicht gegebenenfalls, ich habe vergessen, die Lipid-Profil im Labor kontrollieren zu lassen.
Ich werde auch Lipid-Profil kontrollieren lassen, Entschuldigung.
Wenn der Patient erhöhte Lipid hat, würde ich auch Statin, oder?
Also, Cholesterinsenker.
Ja, Cholesterinsenker verabreichen auch, oder verordnen.
Und noch Entteilungsstörung und ja.
Ja, schon gut.
Und auch vielleicht, aber nicht, vielleicht, der Patient, das ist das zweite Mal für diesen Patienten.
Ich meine die TVT-Attacke, oder TVT.
Vielleicht eine Risikofaktoreinschätzung kann für diese Patienten oder für die Familienangehörigen erforderlich sein.
Weil eine mögliche oder zukünftige Fehler zu vermeiden.
Ja, dass er zum Beispiel regelmäßig einen Kompressionsstrom trägt, oder so.
Ja, gut. Ja, ich denke mal, wir sind fertig.
Also, die unterrichten mich über ihren Patienten, pipapo, gut.
Wir haben eine spannende Analyse gehabt.
Ich hätte gar nicht gedacht, dass ein gammeliges Ulkus so eine interessante Diskussion auslöst.
Aber ich fand es total spannend, weil wirklich viele mitgemacht haben.
Und es ist zwar kein Düsseldorfer Fall.
Das muss ich gerade überlegen. Ich glaube es ist ein Mainzer Fall.
Ich weiß noch nie, wer kommt. Das ist immer eine Überraschung für mich.
Aber es kann ihnen immer passieren, dass ihnen ein Ulkus Kurus über den Weg läuft als Hausarzt.
Insofern ist es nicht schlecht, wenn man weiß, was zu tun ist.
Ja, und wir haben also zwei Teile...
Entschuldigung, mein Gott, ich muss jetzt noch trinken.
So, den ersten Teil haben sie sehr souverän gemacht.
Super Analyse, sprachlich sehr schön, immer schön auf den Patienten eingegangen.
Und auch immer wieder bestätigt. Ich habe das verstanden, was sie gesagt haben.
Ja, das ist eine wichtige Information. Das hat mir sehr gut gefallen.
Und als er so ein bisschen ungeduldig war, als sie nach den anderen Faktoren gefragt haben,
also nach Herz und nach Schwindel oder was auch immer,
das ist trotzdem wichtig für uns, muss ich Sie um Verständnis bitten, haben sie sehr schön gemacht.
Wir sind dann ins Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch gegangen und da habe ich ein bisschen mehr Unsicherheit bemerkt.
Vor allen Dingen eigentlich in der Beschreibung, warum der Patient überhaupt gekommen ist.
Sie haben gesagt, der hat seit einem halben Jahr eine Wunde und jetzt kommt er halt.
Und da habe ich als Oberärztin so ein bisschen nachgehackt und habe gesagt, wieso kommt er ausgerechnet jetzt?
Also plötzlich ist die Wunde tiefer und größer geworden und mit einmal tut sie weh und mit einmal zerniert sie.
Das hat sie vorher nicht getan. Also er hat ganz kleine Verschlechterung da drin.
Gut, das war der Grund, weshalb er gekommen ist.
Und was ich witzig finde, sie haben mich ja gefragt, wie die Schmerzqualität ist.
Und ich habe gesagt, die ist stechend. Es sticht und es drückt.
Und sie haben das einfach nicht erzählt. Sie haben nur gesagt, es drückt.
Also ich habe Gott sei Dank noch nie ein riesiges Ulkos gehabt, aber ich glaube, es sticht schon in so einer Runde nach allem, was ich so mitgekriegt habe, das Leute so erzählen.
Gut, dann ist ihm eben auch aufgefallen, dass das Bein so dick geworden ist und dass das spannend und dass es dunkelblau verfärbt ist.
Das sind ja alles Gründe, weshalb der gekommen ist. Mit einmal sieht das Bein ganz furchtbar aus.
Gut, dann haben sie ausdrücklich gefragt, ob der Patient bemerkt hat, dass das Bein übel riecht.
Und das hat der Fanat gesagt, ich habe nichts gemerkt. Meine Frau hat auch nichts gemerkt. Sie schimpft auch nicht, dass ich stinke.
Aber der Oberärztin haben sie gesagt, die Wunde ist übel riechend. Das passt nicht zusammen. Also haben sie einfach angenommen, dass die Wunde riecht.
Er hat es aber nicht gesagt. Haben Sie verstanden?
Ja, ja.
Gut, da waren sie dann auch bei den Nachfragen in der Satzkonstruktion und in der Formulierung nicht so souverän wie am Anfang.
Am Anfang waren sie, also beim Arzt-Patient-Gespräch, waren sie ja ganz souverän und haben sehr solide formuliert und gab es eigentlich überhaupt nichts zu meckern.
Und da haben sie ein bisschen geschwommen, als sie was frei beschreiben sollten.
Und als sie dann wieder im System drin waren, als sie sagen konnten, was weiß ich, Allergie, da haben sie diese Hautallergie gegen eine Handcreme, haben sie mich erwähnt.
Aber Noxen zum Beispiel, Familienanamnese, das haben sie alles dann wieder gut formuliert, weil es dafür wahrscheinlich Vorformulierungen gibt, die sie gut drauf haben und wo sie dann wieder sicher sind.
Und natürlich auch dann in der weiteren Gespräch, beim Vorgehen in der Untersuchung, was sie alles machen müssen, das war auch alles dann natürlich völlig souverän.
Und auch die Maßnahmen, was man mit den Patienten macht, kam alles zusammen.
Wobei das auch wieder nett war, da haben die Kollegen ja auch sehr engagiert mitgearbeitet.
Ich fand das richtig schön. Dieses Ulkos wurde also von vielen Kollegen mitbehandelt. War ein konsidiarisch behandeltes Ulkos. Sehr schön.
Aber da haben sie sich dann wieder wacker geschlagen. Vielleicht müssten sie so ein bisschen, ja, das ist natürlich schwierig das zu üben, diese Souveränität einen freien Text zu formulieren.
Da muss man wissen, wie geredet wird. Und das kann man immer nur durch Sprechen lernen. Sprechen Sie mit Ihren Kindern Deutsch. Das kann ich Ihnen nur als Tipp geben. Die können es ja.
Und machen sie Alltagsgespräche auf Deutsch, damit sie das üben, wie sie irgendeine nicht vorformulierte Geschichte richtig überbringen.
Das war wirklich nur so eine ganz kleine Schwäche. Ansonsten war es wirklich super.
Ja, gehen Sie munter in Ihre Prüfung. Ohne Sorgen. Wir haben einen interessanten Abend gehabt für mich. Ich fand es wirklich total gut.
Und fand es sehr nett, mit uns alle zusammen. Und vielleicht noch ein Punkt. Ich glaube die Düsseldorfer sind ziemlich krisch mit der Dauer.
Wir haben ein bisschen, sowohl bei der Anamnese als auch beim Arztgespräch, überzogen. Sie haben ein bisschen länger gebraucht.
Aber ich denke mal, das ist kein Weinbruch. Insgesamt fand ich war es wirklich eine gute Geschichte. Und wie gesagt, ich fand es sehr nett, die Zusammenarbeit mit Ihnen allen.
Mir hat es viel Spaß gemacht heute Abend. Und ja, damit würde ich mich von Ihnen allen verabschieden für heute.
Wir sehen uns am Dienstag wieder. Dazwischen liegt jetzt eine ganze Serie von Feiertagen. Danke.
Es liegt eine ganze Serie von Feiertagen vor uns. Morgen ist bei uns Freitag ein ganz wichtiger Feiertag.
Dann kommen die Ostertage, unser großes, wunderbares Osterfest. Und ich freue mich sehr darauf.
Und dann sehen wir uns alle wieder. Von mir aus gerne am Dienstag. Ja?
Und ansonsten genießen Sie die freien Tage. Tschüss zusammen und schönen Abend für heute.
Schönen Abend.
Danke. Tschüss.
Schönen Oster.
Ja, danke.